so huh you wouldn't sit it now what kind
of business go joke Don Lemon ass have
in my work I need your help for a case
come in here with your skinny ass change
your button-down plaid gap shirt idiot
[ __ ] with two eyes on a dick to read
you of mile away please don't use the
n-word what he thinks he's black James
Bond that [ __ ] was real he think
he was me why is it every time I'm
around you it's a [ __ ] gunfight you
trying to act like a little gunfire
don't still turn you up did you walk
around smelling good sir look like [ __ ]
how could you look twenty years older
than my gray ass
I need watch my back oh there's some
simple bit [ __ ] okay we're gonna be what
the [ __ ] are you wearing you sure you
like both yes I like [ __ ] yeah the way
you say [ __ ] don't sound like you like
you describe what a [ __ ] look no I'd
remember [ __ ] a black guy dressed
like Morpheus from matrix what was that
for
sick of these Laurence Fishburne
comparisons chicken oh so now rated R
only in theaters June 14th
[Music]